i cannot tell you how excited i was
when i heard your little giggle in the
teaser
confirming that you were gonna be back
so happy you could come how does it feel
to be back on the show oh
thank you it honestly feels so amazing
guys like below deck is probably one of
the best experiences of my whole life
her second season has just been amazing
yeah
did you know what you were walking into
the state of things
on the wellington no idea like i just
thought that like i was the first
person to come and replace like someone
getting fired i didn't really realize
like how many crew transitions
there had already been so yeah it was
definitely like a bit of a
whoa to hear everything that had gone on
before me and it's actually been really
interesting for me to go back and watch
because obviously like when i came onto
the boat i didn't want to go around
being like
what's what's happened what's happened
what's happened i kind of just tried to
pick up on things so now that i'm
actually watching everything that
happened i'm like
holy sh this season's crazy
you don't think i care hannah do you
think if i wanted you off the boat that
i would use this
huh no it is [ __ ]
because i could have fired you last year
a year before
so did you find out about like how
hannah's exit
unfolded by watching the show yeah
pretty much
i didn't really get the whole hannah
kind of like filled me in a bit more
three or four months later but yeah
watching it was the first time that i
kind of got like the whole
sort of glimpse of what happened yeah
what was your reaction to it because
it's like the wildest thing that's ever
happened in below deck
i know i just felt really sorry for
hannah like you know
she's a very good friend of mine and i'm
really protective of her so seeing her
when she got called into captain sandy's
cabin
and um how vulnerable she looked i just
like wanted to reach out and give her a
big hug she's been on the show for so
long it just seemed like kind of
like a shame that that's how it had to
end yeah i mean it seemed like she was
ready
to say goodbye but i think she would
have liked like
yes she's definitely was ready to go
there and i'm so happy for her she's
been saying for
ages that all she wants is like a baby
you know she's so destined to be a
mother so
now that she's pregnant it's just oh i'm
just so happy
obviously malia is very much tied up in
what happened
to hannah and i feel like the audience
is feeling a certain type of way about
malia because of
what happened do you think the audience
needs to cut her some slack
i feel like malia's obviously just
someone who is
very very passionate about her job and
she's like a real stickler for the rules
i guess that's probably why she felt
inclined to like take the photo and
report it because she is just so
passionate about her job so
yeah i don't know i guess i guess i see
where she's coming from
okay you stepping onto the boat
this charter season feels harder than
your first
is that because of you joining halfway
through
because of the personalities i don't
know what it was about the personalities
on the boat but like because i joined
boats like all the time because i like
the last two years that i did yachting i
was doing temp work so
i'm very used to coming into things late
and i find it really easy to slip into
cruise but for whatever reason this
season
the crew i just found like they just hit
the banter and like i couldn't really
have like
any good back and forth with anyone
thank you
what was that do you say
what and then it means i love you and
that's kind
of like the way that i settle myself
into a yacht and so because i
felt like i wasn't really getting there
i definitely found it a bit harder to
kind of find my place and settle myself
in and i think a big part of that was
the fact that like
so much drama had happened and there was
already like couples and
all that kind of thing so every i don't
know like i guess everything was already
so established
well it seems like you were able to kind
of get to a
banter place with at least rob like you
guys have a little bit of a dynamic
but we're seeing it's rubbing jess the
wrong way
i'm annoyed now i have to watch him
flirt with aisha
[Music]
like what the did you know she was
having these jealousy moments
nah and there's a thing like they're
obviously just showing the stuff of me
and rob because it's relevant but i was
like that with
you know with all of the boys that were
on the boat like i'd say me and alex had
by far the most banter
but it's just because bugsy wasn't
jealous they're not like showing it
i had no idea that jess
was not liking it until the day that she
came to me oh actually i don't know
if i can talk about this because i don't
think it's there yet okay so there might
be until something happens
and then i find out but for for the
majority of the time
i had no clue okay so the jess stuff is
going to come to a head at some point
we're going to see
something occur yeah
[Laughter]
i went back through that mid-season
trailer just to be like what haven't we
seen
it looks like captain sandy is going to
hit like a breaking point
or be pushed to her limits it's about a
team
i want us to be champions not at each
other's throat
but as a line i'm your captain i can't
do insubordination
what is that about um
i don't know i don't know
if i can really answer that she's had a
really
tough season there's been tension
there's been drama she was probably just
feeling overwhelmed which
it seems like a lot of people on board
were
this is true this is true uh somebody
who doesn't seem overwhelmed at least
not yet is bugsy she is just rolling
with the punches
who's the better chief stew bugsy or
hannah i don't think i can say that
there's like a bitter cheese too because
they've both got such different styles
and both of them are really good styles
so i found working with both of them was
like they're very positive experiences
that was a very political answer
[Laughter]
because my dream as a fan of this show
it was kind of rumblings that hannah was
going i was like
aysha new chief stew get her on every
season she's the best cast member we've
ever seen on this show
all things do you want to be a chief
stew
and be the lead for seasons to come i
think
if they asked me it's definitely
something that i would think about
um but i think it's just a tricky one
because i do
feel very checked out of yachting you
know like i
feel like there was a time in my life
and i'm in a new part you know
so i don't know but then if i didn't
have to do yachting
all around the year and i just did the
show like maybe that's something that i
think about but
yeah i'm not really sure okay so the
opportunity would have to present itself
and then you'd actually
face that idea yeah exactly but i would
definitely still want to work in tv
so like if another reality show came
along or
you know like i'd love to do another
bravo show or i'd love to get into
hosting or something like that but yeah
we'll see don't come from my job
yeah no you can't you better you can
take
my biggest dream is to do some sort of
like bravo travel show
and just like put me in really bizarre
situations around the world and just see
how i cope
with it i would 100 watch that i think a
lot of people
all right so you say you're in a
different life place now where are we at
give me the rundown of your life right
now
so at the moment i yeah i've got a new
man
who i'm very in love with as you guys
have probably seen like we live in his
he's converted an ambulance into a
little camper van so
we just kind of live that rugged
outdoors life which we both love
so very colorado very unran for
you yeah i'm here for it and we kind of
just want to try and
do full-time van life next year and just
travel for the whole year
we kind of sounds like a reality show
yeah
yeah come and film me bravo come on
but i don't know i think like yeah we
just want to you know
sit we're going to be 30 at the end of
next year and we kind of were like what
do we want to
what do we want like our last years of
our 20s to look like and we're like we
just want to make the most of it and
like travel as much as we can and
yeah all right so is this guy the one
what's his name
yes i definitely think he's the one uh
his name is scott
scotty scotty dobson and how do you know
each other how did you meet
uh we actually went to high school
together so yeah we had a little little
crush on each other in high school and
then
we just started talking again through
instagram at the end of last year and
yeah
it got to march and i was like well i
want to come over and see you and see if
this goes anywhere and then yeah really
hit it off
okay so
basically the pandemic happened
the world shut down you're like i want
to come live with you yeah
it's actually so funny because like
obviously this pandemic is
has ruined so many things and it's been
like such a negative experience for so
many people but
like in terms of me and him it's been
such a positive experience
i think if it wasn't for for covert we
wouldn't be
like as close as we are now so yeah a
little
love in the time of a corona yeah
exactly
we've got a handful of episodes left
this season
what's going to happen there's going to
be drama in the galley
drama in the and the crew quarters lots
more drama to come so you go
it's going to stay on bran with the
season so good talking to you i'm so
happy you're back
i hope that when we can live our lives
again
they will come to you and say be chief
stu and you'll take it because i want
more of you on my tv
or we'll get you so much
[Music]